fabienne gaston-dreyfus laurence pas
points ou encore souk ang lee toutes
sont ancrés dans le faire et ont en
commun cette spécificité du processus
sous par exemple qu'il ou elle repart
avec des fonds colorés
elle fait d'efforts mais elle repeint
dessus elle reprend et elle utilise le
gommage par l'art peinture
et
l'artiste rejette son propre ego
travaille à l'instinct se sert de sa
pratique
en fait c'est la technique qui lui donne
ses sujets et donc j'ai appris la
technique de la fresque aux arts
appliqués et je m'en suis pas remise doc
chez j'ai pas de peindre sur un tableau
sylvie turpan pratique l'art de la
fresque une méthode utilisée depuis
l'antiquité qui nécessite une grande
habilité
ce qui était important c'était de
réintégrer mon objet tableau enfin ma
fraise que tableau au mur et ils meurent
y meurent fait il fallait un glissement
entre le mur est l'objet
c'est comme ça que j'ai ré introduit les
fonds
on
et moi j'ai cette liberté de construire
le tableau dont qui se déforment voilà
il y a des gens qui en sont plus il
s'étire et donc j'appelle ça des pouces
puisque j'ai l'impression que la fresque
qui est l origine du tableau elle pousse
voilà elle pousse au mur ça pousse je
les arrose tous les jours